when did you meet dad i was eight years
old he was seven because he's a year
younger than me he lived right across
the street in an orange house his dad
was a teacher at the elementary school
george was this very skinny little kid
straight sandy hare and we did things
that kids do we played games on the
street he was in the same grade as me so
we hung out with some of the kids at
school too and i was very good friends
with him until grade seven when i
matured and he didn't because boys don't
mature as fast as girls i left him to
his group of friends and i went on with
my group of friends and we didn't really
hang out again until high school i was
actually going out with another fellow
but i wanted jordan to be my grad escort
because he was my best friend my
boyfriend had to go away around
graduation so i asked george to be my
escort and he said yes so that was our
first date he didn't spend any time with
me though he spent time with his friends
at graduation graduation yeah